can I help you
y-yes yes you can I'm here to report a
terrible crime and what terrible crime
is that this one nah [ __ ] I told this
all wrong
quick history lesson mutual and soon
enough
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah
are we ready named improves after that
Thank You Wayne guy welcome back
everyone it's Charley big surprise they
dropped a brand-new birds-of-prey
trailer so we'll break it down there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs couple more
Batman name drops more Joker name drops
as well as black mask in full comic-book
black mask if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Easter egg videos we're doing a movie
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Harley Quinn moment from
anything on the video there was an
interview a little while ago that Margot
Robbie did about the film explaining
what's going on with the Joker how this
relates to the other DC films and how
they tell the story of this film so the
important thing with the way they're
telling this story is that most of the
film is nonlinear jumping all over
Harley Quinn's timeline until you get to
the third act then it becomes linear so
it's a sort of Harley Quinn being this
unreliable narrator telling you her own
backstory jumping around from event to
event they kind of did the unreliable
narrator thing with Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker movie where you're not quite sure
whether or not you're getting the truth
because you're getting it from his
perspective the whole time so it sounds
like they're using a little bit of that
type of storytelling for the Harley
Quinn birds-of-prey story the song that
plays across this entire trailer is
Bjork's cover of it's so quiet which is
a cover of a Betty Hutton classic show
tune from 1951 they did the same thing
with the last big trailer where you have
Harley Quinn doing Marilyn Monroe from
Gentlemen Prefer Blondes which was also
covered by Madonna later so we don't
know if the entire movie is gonna be
like this or if they just engineered the
trailers to work this way but Harley
Quinn's pageantry is like level 10
during this seriously for most comic
book movies you expect the main
characters to get a couple costume
changes or some upgrades but because
this is Harley Quinn you get like 10
different outfit changes in fact most of
the other birds of prey seemed like they
were the exact same outfits through the
entire movie Harley Quinn is probably
the only one that shows up every 15
minutes in a completely separate outfit
the opening scene of the trailer seems
like it's her rescuing one of the other
birds of prey from lockup it's not clear
which Police Department this is because
later in the trailer you find out that
Renee Montoya is basically being kicked
to the curb because she's trying to
investigate black man
so the rest of the Police Department is
giving her the middle finger laughing at
her for trying to take down black mask
it makes them seem kind of dirty so we
don't know what's going on with this
particular precinct and where
Commissioner Gordon is in all this most
of the time when you see a dirty
precinct in a Batman story Batman winds
up taking that precinct down with the
help of Gordon they give you a little
more context for her backstory with
Joker leading up to the events of this
film because this is coming after the
last Suicide Squad film and in that
post-credit scene Joker shows up to
Belle Reve to break her out so you do
kind of wonder what happened in those
couple years between these movies but if
it wasn't clear this is obviously taking
place after the last Suicide Squad film
but probably before the next Suicide
Squad film that James Gunn is doing that
film will also feature a version of
Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn I'm
assuming it'll be set after the events
of this movie but that's not totally
clear yet so we'll just worry about it
when they start dropping footage for the
next Suicide Squad film but this is
basically Harley Quinn blowing up ace
chemicals to quote-unquote break up with
the Joker to things we could probably
assume here she did not leave a note and
she did not actually kill the Joker
she's just blowing up his quote-unquote
home base I know a lot of you are also
asking where is the Joker how does he
figure into this movie are there any
scenes with Jared Leto's version the
Joker just for continuities sake margot
robbie revealed that there is no Jared
Leto anywhere in this film they did use
a body double for some distant scenes
but you don't actually see the Joker
himself on screen so you wouldn't be
able to tell that it's not Jared Leto
playing the Joker but it's meant to be
his version the rest of the trailer is
dedicated to just explaining what the
actual story is why they come together
why black mask wants to kill every
single one of them as she says during
the trailer turns out when you're not
with the Joker anymore a lot of people
want to kill you they're all terrified
of the Joker the Clown Prince of Crime
even black Basques so now that she's not
with the Joker anymore she's basically
saying that they've declared an open
season on Harley Quinn just look in the
background for a second to it the way
she's decorated her apartment obviously
she's throwing knives at the picture of
the Joker on the back like I said it's
meant to be the Jared Leto version of
the Joker but she's got the stuffed
animal Kleenex holder right next to her
to give you a little more the black mask
plot obviously they're running Gotham
City imports in the MacGuffin of the
film that diamond that Cassandra Cain
winds up swiping it sounds like she just
picked pocketing and she doesn't
what it is she steals till way later
like she sees this giant diamond is like
holy crap what did I just grab from this
dude this is Christmas Anna's Victor
Zsasz character Victor Zsasz obviously
you know from the comics but he's
second-in-command in the movie to human
McGregor's black mask who they're making
sound like the biggest criminal at least
right now in Gotham in this trailer like
they're obviously lots of crime families
in Gotham but during the events of the
film black masters happens to be the
most powerful they start to introduce
the other birds of prey characters this
is Helena Bertinelli Huntress they
explained her in the trailer she wound
up killing when a black mask best
friends they don't say who that was so
you just left a wonder I'm guessing at
some point during the film someone will
reference who that was if it's gonna be
some big Batman comic book character but
for the most part it seems like she's a
pretty authentic version of comic book
Huntress comes from the Bertinelli crime
family but then rejects them and starts
going around killing mobsters one by one
this seems like it's coming from much
later in the film this might be after
she busts her out of prison so maybe it
is Cassandra Cain who's in that lockup
when she goes in at the beginning of the
trailer you can kind of use the trailer
footage to chart the timeline of the
movie based on the different outfits
that Harley Quinn wears because like I
said there are many different outfits
this seems like a very Deadpool esque
scene of Harley Quinn trying to fight
this biker gang off inside this evidence
locker but she sits behind this giant
pile of blow then inhales it in has a
very Deadpool esque who I'm touching
myself kind of moment I have a big plan
and then that things go completely off
the rails if you think it's weird to see
Harley Quinn doing drugs in the trailer
it's probably because the movie is rated
R so it's gonna be a little more
hardcore even though this trailer is a
green band version of the trailer the
biker gang takes a face full of blow so
even though she just kicks the crap out
of them you have to imagine that by the
time they go down she says that dude's
beard on fire
they are probably high as kites more
than cutting loose in the supermarket
having fun doing a big shopping spree
getting food and also getting food for
the hyena there's a giant bag of dog
food in there that you can't see we
finally get an answer about what's going
on with black Canary's canary cry it
turns out she is a metahuman during the
trailer so whatever a continuity you
think this version of Gotham exists in
within the Batman movie mythos there are
still metahumans I mean we still have
characters like the flash so people do
have biological powers it just they
didn't make that really overtly clear
from the last trailer but
here you actually see her using her
sonic canary cry to one break that glass
while she's singing but also to take
that in a giant group of black massive
villains in the parking lot later
Harlequin says she portrayed Black Mass
but it's not clear what she did to
betray black bask all this stuff of them
inside the amusement park as taking
place on amusement Mile which is
obviously a very seminal location within
the Batman mythos for the Joker and the
Harlequin character loved the way they
all react to huntresses unbridled rage
way more black masks suiting up in a
couple different costumes in a bunch of
different sequences also more of the
false face society gang wearing their
masks - we've seen them in the previous
trailers but they just give you much
better look in this trailer they show
you her and Cassandra Cain getting some
burritos it looks like just enjoying the
smell with the hyena in the back which
she's named Bruce after Bruce
wayne/batman it's not clear if Batman is
gonna be featured anywhere during the
movie I'm not expecting him but if
there's this Bruce Wayne reference I'm
assuming there's maybe a couple other
Bruce Wayne references or the big guy
the bad guy maybe just offhanded Batman
remarks without directly referencing
Batman we're in a weird place
cinematically with our version of Batman
because they're making Robert Pattinson
the Batman movie right now we've
actually seen him on set but technically
the Batman of this movie should be Ben
Affleck but it don't know if he's going
to be featured in any of the future
movies even the flash flashpoint movie
that they just announced
there were also a lot of people after
the last trailer that claimed that there
were two hyenas in the back of her car
but this clearly shows that there's one
hyena and instead of it being bud and
Lou from the original animated series
those are the two hyenas that she has
during that she might just have the one
hyena Bruce for most of the movie maybe
she gets another hyena at the end of the
movie - usually when they changed things
like that it's usually for the sake of
practicality like they have a
combination of different types of
special effects to pull off the hyena in
these scenes some of the scenes with it
seems like they're animatronic like when
it's in the bathtub laughing after she
references Batman then because there's a
grand tradition of Harley Quinn
unleashing her hyenas upon people that
she doesn't like the Pliocene where she
uses it to maul someone that'll probably
be full CG they had some of the roller
derby Harlequin scenes I don't know what
kind of roller derby she's doing during
the course of the film maybe that's just
something that she picks up in her free
time after she's not with the Joker
anymore
but they kind of turned it into this big
roller derby action scene later when
she's trying to rescue Cassandra Kane
from black mask in his car the funny
thing about Harley Quinn in this scene
here when she's talking to Huntress
about her rage you have to remember that
dr. Harleen Quinzel was actually a
psychologist at Arkham Asylum before she
became Harley Quinn she was the one that
was brought in to psychoanalyzed the
Joker before he wound up twisting her to
his ways and she became the Harley Quinn
character so just because she's been
Harley Quinn this whole time doesn't
mean that she's still not a really good
psychologist she can't psychoanalyze all
these other people so maybe she does
some of that during the film they got
into a little bit of that backstory
during the last Suicide Squad film but
she's just been in full Harlequin
costume going crazy like comic-book
Harley Quinn for so long you kind of
forget that she actually used to be a
really good doctor there's a big montage
of action scenes from previous trailers
that we've seen from across the movie
then she looks to camera while back in
her car breaking the fourth wall so it
does sound like she's gonna be breaking
the fourth wall a little bit during the
film a little bit Deadpool style not
quite the way the Deadpool does it the
funny thing about the Deadpool in the
Harley Quinn characters is they kind of
use them in similar ways in the comics
to comment on the action of whatever
stories that they're in breaking the
fourth wall is that they both debuted
relatively close to each other in the
early 90s Deadpool came first in New
Mutants number 98 in 1991 Harley Quinn
debuted the next year in 1992 on Batman
the Animated Series in the episode
Joker's favor if you're not a big comic
book reader Harley Quinn is actually
probably one of the most famous examples
of a character in the comics that super
popular in present day that did not
debut originally in the comics she
debuted on the TV show everyone loved it
so they brought her into the comics
everyone loved it even more and she
wanted to become even more popular over
time but everyone let me know in the
comments if you spotted any big Easter
eggs in the trailer that I didn't
mention in the video I will be doing
review videos Easter eggs and everything
for this movie when it comes out next
month I will do a new video about the
flash flashpoint movie there's a couple
big trailers that have just dropped so
I'll try to get to all the videos as
fast as possible including the crisis on
Infinite Earths stuff also named a
giveaway winner when I post that next
trailer video so everyone click here to
learn about Batman himself Christian
Bale showing up in Thor for love and
thunder and click here for my last big
Marvel
you